ok marvel vient de nous offrir du très
lourd avec cette nouvelle bande annonce
qui dure quasiment plus de trois minutes
je vous propose donc une analyse
accompagné de son lot de thé aux rives
par rapport à ce qu'il y aura dans
avengers 4 et bordel qu'est ce que je
suis à ip n'hésitez vraiment pas laissé
un gros pouce bleus et à me dire ce que
vous avez pensé dans les commentaires ça
m'intéresse je lire est d'ailleurs tous
vos commentaires bref
commençons tout d'abord orientons nous
sur le côté général le trailer proposé
par marvel est très malin car il est
conséquent sans rien dévoiler
mais pourquoi ça car nous sommes de
retour sur des scènes passé centrés sur
nos héros principaux tony stark steve
tort la trinité marvel depuis le début
de la saga entière le trailer nous
invite clairement à retourner en arrière
et nous rappeler des moments passés je
pense que vous voyez où je veux en venir
mais c'est clair comme de l'eau de roche
il ya un paradoxe très prononcé avec ses
scènes car elles sont illustrées par des
propos que nos héros tiennent dans le
présent tony stark se rappelle de quand
il est devenu ironman alors
qu'actuellement il est coincé dans un
vaisseau nous alternons entre scènes du
passé et du présent
c'est un indice énorme et justement une
voix qui d'ailleurs me semble être celle
de peggy carter car justement elle
termine sur l'enterrement de peggy
carter parle que la meilleure solution
est justement de tout recommencer et que
justement au moment où elle dit tout
recommencer elle se termine sur
l'enterrement de peggy carter mais
également sur le visage de steve rogers
je reviens sur lui encore mais steve
mérite clairement sa dernière danse avec
peggy carter après être retourné d'antan
j'ai d'ailleurs fait une grosse
découverte à ce sujet qui pourrait
prouver son retour dans le passé
si nous nous intéressons au précédent
trailer nous voyons steve regardez la
photo de péguy ceci est en fait une
référence au soldat de l'hiver c'est
exactement le même plan ce n'est
vraiment pas un hasard marvel joue avec
nous mais on parle de steve tient ce
dernier a donné l'élément qui prouve
enfin le voyage dans le temps dans un
jeune george iv ou du moins
un certain retour en arrière je n'arrête
pas de dire qu'il faut avancer
il est vrai que le capitaine est un
petit peu le leader des troupes celui
qui pousse les autres à aller de l'avant
celui qui essaie de pousser les autres à
trouver le courage d'avancer
cependant il termine avec un air
d'ailleurs assez sarcastique que
certains le font mais pas nous je ne
peux pas être plus clair concernant
cette scène toute la première partie du
trailer est orientée sur le passé pour
justement aller de l'avant dans le passé
se rappeler de tous ces moments qu'on a
vécus se rappeler des difficultés des
gloires des erreurs et qu'il va lui
falloir corriger certaines choses
remodelée à partir de ce qui a été fait
faire un reset la phrase de steve se
termine d'ailleurs sur un passage de
scott langues
ceux ci symbolise pour moi que quand man
est clairement la clé permettant aux
avengers de retourner dans le temps ou
du moins
faire un voyage quantique son visage
n'est pas montrée par hasard il est
montré par rapport au fait que steve
confirme qu'on va retourner en arrière
d'ailleurs antoine semble très troublée
l'endroit où il est et délabré et
abandonné on peut affirmer haut et fort
quand man et dans le présent d'avengers
par le biais des affiches avec marquez
et missing et le fait que la maison ne
soit plus habiter suite au claquement de
doigts de thanos il semble très perdu et
désorienté combien de temps est-il resté
dans le champ quantique
on ne le sait pas mais surtout il ne
sait pas du tout ce qu'il s'est passé
il ne sait rien du claquement de doigts
de thanos ou comment ses compagnons
disparus
cette scène est clairement la découverte
du monde après une finity voir ensuite
nous avons le plan des vaisseaux des
avengers se dirigeant vers new york
probablement pour mener à bien leurs
plans et accessoirement montrer que la
ville reste encore assez active malgré
le 50% en moins ce qui est tout de même
d'ailleurs assez troublant car dans les
précédents trailer la ville était
clairement montré comme inhabitée pour
accentuer le côté beaucoup de pertes le
côté et disparus des fêtes
bref vous voyez ce que je veux dire
enfin natasha affirme qu'il n'ya qu'une
infime chance qu'il réussisse comme quoi
ils savent que la mission est très
risqué c'est même d'ailleurs assez
marrant car nous pourrions lié ceci par
rapport à doctor strange avec sont une
chance sur 14 millions mais puisque tony
semble être revenu il aurait peut être
communiquée aux autres à ce sujet d'où
le fait que natacha dit ceci on pourrait
lier tout ça et il y aurait donc une
certaine cohérence visuellement elle
semble en mission avec hawk eye comme à
la bonne vieille époque prouvant le
retour aux sources et confirmant le fait
que le groupe sera scindé en plusieurs
petits groupes pour mener à bien la
mission
enfin le trailer se conclut sur
plusieurs plans des héros restent en
affirmant qu'ils feront tout pour
réussir
quel qu'en soit le prix le
quel qu'en soit le prix est clairement
ici pour montrer que les avengers n'ont
plus rien à perdre et qu'ils sont
d'ailleurs prêts à mourir pour mener à
bien la mission et la réussir le plus
flagrant pour moi est le fait que tony
stark soit extrêmement souligné au
moment où il dit quel qu'en soit le prix
nous montrant qu'au final il est de
retour en compagnie de nebula c'est
quelque chose qui me sidère un petit peu
beaucoup quand même car le premier
trailer accentué énormément le côté
abandon et fin de tony stark coincé dans
le vaisseau contrairement à ce moment
donc comme quoi marvel joue extrêmement
bien avec nous et nos émotions
n'oubliez pas que cependant rien ne nous
a été réellement montré à part des idées
le voyage dans le temps ou du moins le
voyage quantique et montrer de manière
assez implicite mais bon c'est quand
même extrêmement bien lisible on va pas
se le cacher je suis vraiment heureux de
ne pas avoir fait d'erreur là dessus
mais bon rien n'est encore sûr pour le
moment ce n'est qu'un trailer alors
effectivement les combinaisons qui avait
été leakée sont finalement présente est
confirmée dans le film ces nouvelles
combinaisons d'ailleurs pourrait avoir
peut-être un peu voir assez spécial
comme supporter un voyage dans le temps
ou un voyage dans le champ quantique par
exemple même antoine laporte alors qu'il
a déjà sa combinaison normalement ou
encore nebula qui n'est pas du tout une
aventure earth à la base plusieurs
détails peuvent également nous
interpeller il ya donc bien captain
marvel dans le film on la voit à la fin
et la scène semble être justement situé
juste après qu'elle ait fait
connaissance on va dire avec thor
natacha etc
après qu'elle soit arrivée enfin du
moins ce n'est que mon avis cependant un
autre détail me titille énormément tort
possède son marteau et non stormbreaker
marteau qui fut normalement détruits par
ela dans le film thor rania rock
alors comment pourrait-il le posséder de
nouveau peut être un retour dans le
passé
pourtant la scène le sous-entend pas car
on a l'air d'être encore au début du
film
c'est très étrange ou bien la coupe de
cheveux de natacha redevenir ou sedan
endgame mais qui redevient blonde comme
dans une finition noire
c'est un détail qui est important de
noter aussi je pense et que je ne
saurais expliquer
finir je trouve que ce trailer comme le
premier est réellement accentuée sur une
note de rédemption et de sacrifices et
évidemment il y aura des pertes dans nos
héros steve est le plus suspecté de nous
quitter mais le trailer ici mise
également beaucoup sur tony stark malgré
son retour ce sont les deux avengers les
plus probables de nous laisser ce serait
une conclusion très marquante pour le mc
eu
nous sommes quand même à la fin de la
phase 3 la fin d'une très très grosse
épopée qui marquera notre génération
j'appuie aussi sur le fait que thanos
est encore absent des traileurs pour moi
c'est clairement pour dire qu'on ne peut
pas seulement retrouvé à nocé lui casser
la gueule comme captain marvel pourrait
le faire par exemple
d'ailleurs qu'est ce que ça apporterait
personnes seraient de retour mais tanoh
serait mort donc aucune solution il faut
en trouver une autre
bref j'ai plus que hâte de voir avengers
4 je n'en peux plus d'attendre je suis
beaucoup trop hype et maintenant j'en
profite pour vous dire que le 29 mars
quelque chose d'énorme
concernant le mc eu arrive sur la chaîne
et que je ne serai pas seul à vous de
deviner qui viendra m'épauler par
rapport à ce trailer vous invite
également à voir mes vidéos les
conséquences d'avengers 4a concernant le
voyage dans le temps ces risques et le
rôle de docteur strange ou encore ma
vidéo sont très totalement sur steve
rogers par rapport à apple georges 4 ce
sont deux vidéos qui reste au final
beaucoup dans le vrai par rapport à ce
trailer et je pense qu'elle mériterait
un plus large succès elle pourrait
vraiment vous intéresser donc n'hésitez
pas à aller les voir
je vous invite à laisser un gros pouce
bleus si la vidéo vous a plu évidemment
n'oubliez pas d'activer la cloche de
vous abonner ou de me suivre sur twitter
on se retrouve très vite pour de
nouvelles vidéo marvel c'était argot
rock et que le lay honneur soit avec
vous
[Musique]